hasn't attempted a shot yet nice
hesitation move
and finishing with the left hand down by
four and in a rush
with intent attacking the bucket to use
my frame look at the strides at the rim
reaching and slapping just not good
enough answers and the celtics
there has never been a sweep between
them
there's a two-man game with
burks and horford a mismatch against
kembon kimball walker strips him reed
little side pick and roll they forced it
out of his hands
tatum down low against shake milton took
it into contact
count it and one for brett brown
kimba slammed on the brakes sixers have
been called for today
looks like he uses the celtics with
their biggest lead of the game
tatum tough step
back butter jason tatum drills the
mid-range shot
legit defensive player of the year
candidate i had him first team all
defense i did not have them top three
but i'll tell you this his head hit the
court hard on the landing
when he collided with jason tatum nedo
had it blocked by tatum
slapped and packed against the glass
careless turnover in the half court
he tries to cross the body jason tatum
says no
sir
boy that's an emphatic play 12 point
lead
10 on the shot clock the lob tatum snuck
back doran's 23.8 rebounds
richardson threw the traffic had it
blocked
burke's had it blocked the shot clock
down to 3.1
and they throw it over embiid's head
they turn it over on the inbound tatum
with the finger roll turnover costly
at a critical moment for the celtics